miranda in los angeles california how in
the world are you
i'm good um i just
as you know california is kind of crazy
right now with like
everything political going on and i just
wanted to call and ask you like
hold on miranda hold on miranda i have
no idea what you're talking about
california's crazy
just kidding just kidding yeah it feels
like a zoo
it feels like an absolute zoo
yes it's you know and yeah that's what i
think i'm calling to because i just like
i know the election's almost over
but um i think just i'm 21 years old and
i was born and raised in california
and so and i am christian um so i do
lean more towards a conservative side
but i think i was just calling because i
want to ask like how do i navigate
through this like
and i've been having a lot of healthy
conversations with people but i i've
been having some hard conversations too
with people who
don't necessarily agree with me and that
is totally fine
but i just want to know like how do i
talk to people who just don't want to
hear it at all or who don't want to sit
down with adults
and talk about like our differences oh
you're not going to like my answer but
you just don't
yeah people if people don't want to talk
to you if they don't have any interest
in being friends with somebody that
thinks differently
than they do or has different
experiences than they do
then you just you brush your shoulders
off and you bounce you know what i mean
like
it's you're just gonna end up beating
your head up against the wall
give me an example of something that's
happened like that
well um so uh you i i'm very open person
like even though i am christian and
conservative i'm like hey like i want to
hear you i want to talk with you so i'll
sit down with somebody
and we'll talk about it um but recently
one of my family members
has gotten offended by my political view
and i know a lot of people don't agree
with me but uh like our president i
don't agree with everything he says but
i do like his views i do like his
policies so i
lean more towards him okay and so i was
trying to tell my cousin hey like
i like him because of this and i was
giving her good evidence like policies
you know
and she's like i don't want to hear it
and she called me
a white supremacist and i was like oh
like
i am not that at all like i just like
the way he thinks like i like what he's
doing you know
and she happens to also be
african-american and mexican
so she kind of got offended and said
that
like i feel certain way towards
african-american community and i don't
at all
so i think that was a hard conversation
and she hasn't talked to me so i was
like
okay so i just kind of left it alone
sure well yeah that's an example
so i think it's i think it's important
that at the end of the day all you can
control is you
and yeah a a
way that i have adopted navigating the
world and this is new for me this is
just a few years old
and it's it's given me so much more
empathy for the world and so much more
peace in my life
and really i think made me a better dad
and a better husband and a better
community member
which is remembering that everyone
around me
everyone is fighting a secret battle
every day
people have hurts in their hearts and
their minds
that i will never see i will never
experience i will never
know and so when somebody says something
like
you're a white supremacist and you're
thinking no i'm not
then you can do one of two things you
can choose to go to war with that person
and put a stick in the ground and say
i'm gonna die on this hill
or you can say man that person has
some experiences that i don't understand
that person's hurting
and i know that i'm not but i also know
that
going to war with somebody doesn't
change their heart it just ends with a
couple of bodies on the ground
and so instead of going to war i'm just
going to love that person
or maybe once the smoke clears on that
particular argument i'm going to circle
back and say hey walk me through what
you meant by white supremacists because
i don't see myself that way
and does that make sense and i know
we're talking about an egregious thing
here but
um these kind of conversations have been
going on for years and years and years
and they feel like they're at an apex
they're probably not
but everything feels so divisive
everything
from what car you drive and where you
live and and what you
wear and what you listen to all of it
has become so divisive
and so trying to solve what's in the
heart and mind of somebody else you just
can't do
you are more than entitled to your
beliefs and your opinions
that's what this great country's founded
on right
and yeah that comes with the the
understanding that she does too
and other people can choose to not like
you that's totally fair
it hurts but it's totally fair other
people can choose to say your beliefs
make you fill in the blank
they may not be true they may not um
represent what's in your heart and mind
but
we're in a place where people have free
speech and they're allowed to do that
too we've reached this
madness apex where we're trying to
control what other people think and what
they say
and it's just gotten insane it's gotten
nuts right
and so at the end of the day you can
just control you
and the best thing you can do for the
folks around you is just to respond in
love
right that's that's that's the
that's the lever you've got or you
respond with a hammer and i'll just tell
you
people who respond with hammers often
look like idiots
they don't solve the problem they just
make it worse right they just bring
gasoline to a
a fireworks show right it just doesn't
make any sense
and so yeah um be open to listening to
other people's
perspectives invite other perspectives
into your heart and mind i think that's
so
important man and
if someone doesn't want to be your
friend they don't be your friend right
yeah absolutely i think i just had a
hard time with it too because she is
older than me
she's someone i've like looked to like
for her experiences because she's a hard
worker she has a degree like she
has done great for herself but just a
certain decision she's made in her life
i just don't agree with and that's okay
you know and i've invited her to look
into the bible and talk with her and sit
with her
and even when she was being rude to me
like over
like text message all i kept saying was
i love her you know sure but
i just think like in that situation it
was fine like i didn't really hurt me
but i was just like
disappointed you know yeah and i think
when someone's attacking you and you're
trying to like say you love them it's
like
wait what well you just you brought
forth a really
important point having
any sort i want everyone listening this
to hear this
having any sort of of
delicate nuanced or even
angry conversation any sort of robust
dialogue back and forth
over text message is clinically insane
it's just ridiculous and dumb and stupid
and pointless
and idiotic and i'm trying to think of
all the words i can just
writing off top of my head it's just
madness
don't do it right call somebody on the
phone
if you want to talk politics call them
on the phone or sit with them in person
and if you're in los angeles i think you
probably have to be outside
with a hazmat suit on whatever that
looks like for you but
but have that conversation in person
have it in person yeah don't do it in
text because here's why
she may have been laughing the whole
time she may absolutely know you're not
a white supremacist and she's texting
that because she's just trying to be
funny
and you heard it in a way that hurts now
maybe not probably not but
when you you lose all context when you
just strip it away with
with thumbs and zeros and ones zeros and
ones yours and ones right
um yeah yeah don't say those you were
shouting profanity at me so there's
always that too right
right so clearly she may have been um
been
upset but yeah so much of that is
mitigated when you have in-person
conversations
when two people who disagree are sitting
around a table when two people are
sitting around a blanket in a in a
in a park somewhere two people are going
for a walk together
that's when you have real conversations
that's why the digital interactions have
just
jumped a shark they're not even real
anymore it's insanity
so yeah i i would with all of my heart
and mind and soul
miranda i'd recommend you call her
say hey let's have a conversation in
person i'd love to get together i'll buy
the coffee
i don't even know if you're allowed to
drink coffee in california anymore um
but if you are
i'm just kidding i'm just being
ridiculous um but yeah grab coffee and
y'all get together
and then talk about these differences
and say hey you said this
and walk me through what you meant by
that and let them explain
if you call somebody to have coffee and
you're just ready geared up you have all
these imaginary
ugly conversations and you're like yeah
yeah yeah and then i'm gonna tell her
this and i'm gonna tell her this
man then you're going in there for a
fight she'll feel it she'll respond with
a fight and that meeting will be
completely useless and pointless
so all you can control is you when
somebody doesn't agree with you
somebody has a different opinion than
you you can control you and so just
assume that other people have different
experiences than you
different perspectives don't assume
everyone around you is dumb
i've got a group of guys right now that
i've known for years and years and years
and we have some text threads that we
exchange we've got some articles that we
go back and forth
it's michael and kevin two guys that i
love and they i give permission to speak
into my life
and we disagree on a lot of stuff but i
also know
beneath those disagreements those are
two guys that love their families they
love their country they love their
neighborhood they love their church they
love
the least of these in their communities
and they work really really hard at
their jobs they're good
solid men and that means we're anchored
in
and now we can rappel off the side in an
exchange of ideas in exchange
of disagreements and we're all going to
do that safely and we're all going to do
that
with character and with love and i also
want to challenge everybody to do this
you only learn from people who have
different ideas than you
and if you just seek a constant stream
of confirmation about what you already
believe
about what you already think you know
you are not
stretching yourself you are not learning
it's like going to the gym
and lifting weights that you know you
can already lift
you're never going to get stronger
you're never going to get
um in better shape you're never going to
get more fit
you're just going to become this echo
chamber
of opinions that don't go anywhere
so here's a couple of my rules rule
number one
have friends that think differently than
you do have friends that look
differently than you do have friends and
i'm not talking about acquaintances i'm
talking about close friends that sit at
your table
that live differently than you because
you're going to find out that most of
the time there's a
shared humanity that is much greater
than any difference you're going to have
much much greater you're also going to
realize that some of your opinions that
you hold so tight and so dear to
are wrong they're just incorrect
and sometimes if you're like me you're
going to have to look backwards at a
wake of people that you have hurt over
the years or you've given incorrect
information to over the years
and you're going to have to apologize in
your heart if you still know those
people you're going to apologize to them
and you have to work really hard to do
better
you have to really really hard to do
better um
maya angelou says do the best you can
and then when you know more
then go do better and the only way you
can know more is by being around people
who think differently than you do
the second thing is read different
things
read books that challenge you if you are
entrenched in this position
find a book find not articles because
those can be nonsensical sometimes
find books can too but find respected
literature find fiction find things that
make you uncomfortable politically
ideologically and read them read them
and some of it is drivel some of it is
just nonsense it's just
vomit on old sheets of paper right
but some of it really will challenge you
and will cause you to go back to your
original sources
so if you're a person of faith whatever
your faith trajectory is
it's going to go back to your whether
it's the bible or the quran you have to
look at that and say
hmm i i thought this the scientist is
saying this this author gives a
compelling argument let me go back and
see if i
read this wrong or if i felt this wrong
i'm going to go back and call people
i meet with one or two people every
single week
and say hey i had these thoughts this
week i don't know if they're right
you're wise you've you're studied in
these areas
let's dig in but the point is i
intentionally put myself
with ideas that i don't agree with that
are different from me
because that's the only way i'm going to
learn that's why when i go to the gym
at my house i constantly am adding
heavier weight so i can get stronger
i'm constantly looking up wackier
workout programs so that i can
get more limber my body can move better
as i get older
um i'm constantly trying to find people
who are parenting better than me who are
being better husbands than me i want to
surround myself with people who do
things different so i can grow
you've got to do that too get out of the
echo chambers in our phones
our news cycles our digital media
it's built to give us just the things
that we already think
so you've got to be intentional about
reading things that you disagree with
about
listening to things you disagree with
about reading about being around people
you disagree with
and you're going to find yourself a more
robust person
trust me just do it
do it do it do it and make sure you seek
wise counsel because
when you are not a person of ideas
little gk chesters and quote
when you're not a person of ideas any
new idea sounds sexy and cool and like
whew let's go jump into this one right
um man there's so many when it comes to
diet and nutrition
and climate there's all the oh it's
going to be this and everybody just
jumps off this and then the scientists
are like hey
that's not really accurate we're over
here um so have wise people
right have wise people who are learned
they know what they're talking about
and not somebody who just reads a couple
of editorials or a couple of
click bait things on yahoo news or
whatever but be around wise people who
think differently than you i'm going to
quit ranting on that because i talk
about that all day